[Música]
y es que nuestro tema del día hablamos
de la conferencia a la onu sobre el
clima la cob 26 que se desarrolla en
glasgow en escocia se espera que tras
los son mal interpretados y mal
implementados acuerdos de parís de 2015
en esta edición los líderes mundiales
activistas por encima de los expertos
llegan finalmente a acuerdos tangibles
para poder así frenar el calentamiento
global y reducir las emisiones de
carbono evitar que finalmente el mundo
se siga calentando para ello quiero
saludar entonces a uno de nuestros
invitados de la república arcía director
legislativo de comunidades saludables de
air & justice y también está con
nosotros a víctor ramírez socio director
de perceptiva 21 energía firma de
consultoría especializada en el sector
en el sector energético raúl víctor
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 como lo
adelantábamos entonces comenzamos
hablando de esta cop 26 que podemos
esperar cuáles son las conclusiones que
podemos esperar de esta cumbre empiezo
con raúl
bueno creo que lo que queremos ver son
soluciones concretas a la crisis que
estamos viviendo verdad creo que ya han
habido muchos acuerdos en términos de
teoría y demás lo que tenemos que hacer
ahora es ver una reducción concreta en
términos de nuestra contaminación
resguardando nuestra economía y al mismo
tiempo resguardando nuestro futuro el
futuro de nos puesto
víctor le saludo muy buen día podemos
esperar compromisos vinculantes entre
las potencias realmente para entonces
empezar a implementarlos
hola muy buen día pues yo creo que sí
vamos a ver algunos compromisos sobre
todo porque la pandemia nos dio algunas
claves de por dónde pueden ir las cosas
la realidad es que uno
una fuerte vuelta hacia
economías con
perdón con bajos niveles de misiones del
inicio de carbono entonces parece ser
que si puede haber este y además los
países y no solamente respuestas sino
las empresas empezaron a voltear a ver
hacia este futuro con menos emisiones y
creo que podrá haber un gran compromiso
tanto del sector público como de los
sectores privados
el sector prueba muy importante
justamente en el discurso del príncipe
carlos hablaba de esa alianza de
gobierno con sector privado para poder
lograr finalmente estas emisiones de
carbono lograr esta energía limpia y
limpia perdón energía verde raúl él le
preguntó entonces la diferencia que
podemos ver desde la cumbre de parís del
año 2015 está si realmente va a ser más
efectiva ya estaban además diciendo
prendiendo las alarmas que el mundo ya
no aguanta más estamos en el último
minuto de cara a esta crisis climática
global raúl cuál es la diferencia
bueno creo que definitivamente por el
lado de uno de una de las naciones más
importantes genéticos en este acuerdo
eeuu ya vemos una actitud completamente
diferente a la que estuvo presente
durante los últimos cuatro años antes de
que llegara el presidente de baile en
verdad entonces estamos viendo que ya
hay compromiso también en la agenda
doméstica del presidente bailen se está
viendo también avance en términos de
acuerdos durante en medio del congreso
de eeuu para para también reducir estas
contaminaciones esto es lo que aporta es
es el tener un compromiso para que todos
los demás países todos los demás
gobiernos y también el sector privado
vean que realmente hay una inversión en
este tipo de
aporte para que todos sigamos empujando
de la misma manera así ya no estamos
nada más hablando en retórica o
simplemente en mensajería lo que
realmente estamos viendo son acciones
concretas una inversión fuerte de parte
de uno de los países más importantes en
este acuerdo para tratar de lidiar con
esta crisis climática víctor quiero
volver contigo para hablar de dos
ausentes en esta cumbre no hablamos del
presidente chino xi jinping y también el
de turquía recep tayip erdogán sobre
todo china uno de los mayores emisores
de co2 uno de los mayores contaminantes
del mundo qué mensaje les quieren dar
entonces estos líderes mundiales a esta
emergencia climática que al final nos
afecta a todos
bueno tal parece que no le están dando
al menos en la inexistencia como lo
mencionas podría ser que me leyendo la
importancia necesaria sin embargo hay
que decirle también estos países han
apostado también al menos china ha
apostado de una fuerte forma a las
energías limpias a soldar por ejemplo se
han vuelto el primer productor mundial
de paneles solares sin embargo pues si
se esperaría la presencia de ellos para
reforzar esta lucha con el cambio
climático y son ausencias que pesan pero
esperemos que al fin del día haya
acuerdos y que los aprovechar
vinculantes incluso ante la ausencia de
estas dos personalidades
así es regular a la quiero preguntar por
otro tema esto de la energía sostenible
la energía verde a la que todos queremos
llegar no digamos que de alguna manera
los países desarrollados más
industrializados y más ricos del mundo
lo tienen un poco fácil con respecto y
en comparación a nuestra región américa
latina le pregunto cómo lograr ese
balance aquí en nuestra región en
américa latina
muy desigual con pocos recursos también
económicos para esto cómo se logra
cuáles son las recomendaciones lo mejor
que ustedes le pueden hacer a los
gobiernos de latinoamericanos para poder
lograrlo lo antes posible además porque
ya estamos contrarreloj
y definitivamente estamos viendo que
esta inversión se tiene que administrar
de una manera equitativa y para hacer
eso tenemos que enfocarnos en no
solamente en lo que queremos hacer a
nivel federal en todos estos países a
nivel internacional pero también
escuchar a las comunidades con las que
estamos trabajando en términos de
américa latina tenemos que ver dónde es
que la gente esté junta verdad ya
estamos hablando de bibliotecas públicas
y estamos hablando de parques allí es
donde se pueden poner por ejemplo
de presupuestos para paneles solares que
sean comunitarios que puedan proveer
y proveer energía a muchas casas a
muchas familias estando en una en una
zona centralizada donde todos pueden
tener acceso a ella entonces no
solamente estamos hablando de imponer
energía renovable pero también estamos
hablando de poner acceso a esta energía
y el acceso requiere que las comunidades
sean escuchadas por sus gobiernos y que
se invierta de una manera que sea que
responda a cómo esas comunidades están
relacionándose con sus sistemas de
energía y aparte con su consumo de
energía